j'avais une prof de français mais qui
était qui était que j'adorais bof
inquiets qui est toujours vivante
d'ailleurs ça fait comment madame manon
ça fait ma prof de français de latin et
de grec s'il vous plaît voilà je te
muriel peut nous dire parce que muriel
est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
sulfureux comme base à 6,06 et cyril
féraud et bien vous participerez haslam
ils feront à ces dames copains d'accords
dont celui voilà selon sûr mais je te
jure qu'on fait c'est gérard jugnot et
ses amis et c'est pour la promo du film
même s'il faut un peu tard mais pour le
prochain film pour le prochain film pour
une association aba les aides je connais
l'alphabet grec parker à l'isie alfa
beta gamma delta epsilon état est apte
et taille haute à capa lambda minuk si
omicron pire au sigma tau upsilon filles
équipe 6 oméga g2g le tee shirt de
l'époque dernière voilà je vais ramener
mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour le slam on applaudit
de l'arize qui est à vos côtés bonjour
la route qu'est ce que vous faites dans
la vie je suis professeur de zumba voilà
comment on fait je suis alors vous me
suivez
ouais ok c'est bon pour leur venir vous
avez un air des nuages comme de cyril
hanouna n'entre pas soit pas le public
un petit air je sais pas moi j'y peux
rien moi de vous ouvrir un celi ya pire
comme ça va plus les lettres manque deux
fois pour avoir de l'appétit de
l'appétit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
je les ai connus
en fait je suis quasi percevez vous êtes
cyril hanouna mais j'ai juste un truc
qui m'énerve c'est qu'ils aient pas
comme ça normalement
bon je suis désolée la remise pour faire
un câlin oui il faut bien je peux aller
aux jo j'ai cru que c'était une perruque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or
[Applaudissements]